[Music]
uh my name is brian
marescu so this is the immortality key
the secret history
of the religion with no name uh believe
it or not it took me about 12 years
to research and write this book
and i'd like to share with you what that
key is and there's a reason that the
title of this talk is
how to die before you die because as i
found it through the course of my
research
this is really one of the ancient
principles uh that was prized in
antiquity and i think across time
this concept of dying before dying dying
in this life um in some kind of real
sense
in order to achieve a sense of
immortality
let's go down this rabbit hole of
history and try and find out the answer
to the best kept secret
in history which is not fancy marketing
uh this is what a houston smith perhaps
the most influential scholar
uh religious scholar of the 20th century
referred to this hunt as
which in some ways is a hunt for the
holy grail the best kept secret in
history
as houston smith saw it were the
original sacraments of western
civilization
so i went in hunt of not just any
sacrament from ancient greece or early
christianity
but i went in hunt of psychedelic
sacraments specifically
um this is not my theory this is an old
idea
from at least the 1970s as you can tell
from the ties in this photo
this this this idea was written about
before then but the way it came across
my radar most people's radar was in 1978
this scandalous book was published the
road to ellucis
unveiling the secret of the mysteries
now ellustis for those who don't know
is kind of like the spiritual capital of
the ancient world maybe the vatican
of the ancient greece about 13 miles
northwest of athens pilgrims for 2 000
years
would trek to this temple to drink a
magic potion
and become divine to confront their fear
of death to overcome that fear of death
and become immortal hence the same theme
about dying before dying
something happened there in ellucis and
we're not sure exactly what
but it had to do with uh with achieving
divinity there's a great greek word for
this apotheosis
and these two gentlemen were well aware
of the lore and legends
behind ellucis and in 1978 they released
this scandalous book on the left is
albert hofmann
who if anyone knows about psychedelics
would be albert he
famously synthesized lsd uh back in the
1930s from this naturally occurring
fungus called
ergot so i'm not sure if people have
heard of ergot
but it's this natural fungus that
produces all kinds of crazy alkaloids
including lsd and on his right is his
co-author gordon watson
uh now you might not know who gordon is
but in 1955 he traveled to mexico to
participate
in this ceremony with psilocybin
containing mushrooms and he's largely
responsible
for uh the the birth of the pop
psychedelic movement in the 1960s i mean
after
uh after gordon went to mexico he was
followed by the likes of led zeppelin
the rolling stones and bob dylan and
everybody else
so so that individual was really
responsible for what would happen
in the generation to come he teams up
not only with with albert uh the lsd
expert but with
uh the fellow on the left there who's a
guy named carl ruck
he's a professor of classics at boston
university in the picture there he's
only a couple years older than me
actually he's now
85 years old and he joined up with
gordon and albert
to try and tease out the details for
this psychedelic potion
atalusis uh so in the ancient records we
have some sense
of what that potion was we know it was
kind of like a primitive beer
like a barley based potion that was
mixed with water
and mint and that's pretty much all we
have and so
this figure has spent the past four
decades and there he is today
trying to prove that that magical potion
from ellucis again the spiritual
capital of the ancient world that called
to everybody from plato
to marcus aurelius for over 2000 years
carl has spent his career as a
classicist
trying to prove that that potion really
at the seat
at the foundation of western
civilization was a psychedelic potion
and their their book is very interesting
on you know they use literary sources
they look at archaeological sources
the thing is at the time in the late
1970s there wasn't
a lot of hard data um since
since the publication of that book and
relatively recently over the past
10 20 years new sciences have come along
um like archaeochemistry
which is the as the name implies the
combination of
not just excavation field work but
actual chemistry organic chemistry
looking into the contents of some of
these ancient chalices and so
for the very first time we're actually
able to peer in
to the past by by by tapping into the
residue
that was left in some of these
challenges and containers and vessels
from antiquity it's a very exciting time
and so um
i first came across this idea in the
late 90s when i was a a class assist
myself as an undergrad and i since went
to law school
and abandoned the whole hunt but then it
all came back on my radar in about 2007
when i started reading about
uh these psychedelic studies these
clinical studies happening at johns
hopkins and nyu and elsewhere and the
testimony from those people
uh was really strange to me these people
with one and only dose of psilocybin
were talking about very mysterious
things very mystical
quasi-religious experiences you have
atheists talking about finding god for
example
uh with one only dose of this potent
psychedelic and so
it occurred to me that if that's
happening today why wasn't that
happening
2000 years ago or 20 000 years ago
and so i went on a mad hunt for 12 years
to try and find
the hard scientific data to test this
crazy psych
psychedelic hypothesis once and for all
to see if there was
some truth to it so i made my way over
to ellucis
to this um ancient spiritual capital a
couple years ago and i got to talking
uh with the archaeologists the
excavators on site there
um and i found myself walking through
the ancient temple grounds and
meandering into the museum and looking
at all these artifacts of whatever was
happening here
two and a half thousand years ago
perhaps three thousand years ago
um and inside the museum you see lots of
chalices like this so
you know we we know this potion was
there we don't know the exact sequence
of events
when it was drunk how it was drunk but
we do know that
as many as 3 000 people at one time
could cram their way
into this temple on site there that was
dedicated to demeter
the goddess of the grain hence a beer
potion and her daughter persephone who's
famously abducted into the underworld
uh by the king of death hades and then
is resurrected
so there's some intensely ritual element
there
there's something really meaningful
happening here in this death
and rebirth experience it wasn't just
about witnessing
the death and rebirth of persephone
herself from the testimony that that
survived the initiates
themselves went through some kind of
visceral
experience plato himself talks about
witnessing the blessed sight and vision
that could be captured at lucius again
which begs the question was this some
kind of theatrical performance
something you saw with the physical eyes
or was this something
that really happened within the mind's
eye and was there a potion
you know splashing around these ancient
vessels these ancient chalices these
grails
that somehow gave access in some
mind-altering state
to a higher sense of reality and and i
love to look at this artifact in
particular
because i find it kind of mind-blowing
um carl
kerenyi who's a very mainstream
classicist scholar
writing in the 1960s really really harps
on this piece specifically which
obviously comes from the classical
period
it was found at the sanctuary and it's
it's referred to as the ukrate's votive
relief
and in greek at the bottom there you see
ukrates on the right his name is
inscribed there
and before it is the word demeter and we
think or carl thinks that
uh this is actually dedicated to
persephone whose name shall never be
mentioned
so this is this is already working in
coded language but what what kerenyi
says about this artifact is spectacular
he says that what you have here is
someone leaving
testimony um a votive thanks a
thanksgiving
to demeter and persephone for restoring
his vision
uh cadeny talks about this blind person
this blind initiate
going to ellucis and somehow having
their sight restored i mean how can that
happen
we're talking about something very
supernatural um and yet there are
mainstream scholars who have been
been really trying to figure out what it
was about this vision this beatific
vision
in fact kidney uses that term
specifically and he bars it from the
language of christianity to describe
what was happening at this ellucis site
uh and so again
all the circumstantial data kind of
points to
something whether that was a psychedelic
brew or not
i i spent all these years trying to
figure out and
it took me back two at least twelve
thousand years
uh so what you have here um is gobekli
tepe
which is this archaeological site that
was unearthed in the 1990s
um and uh what's fascinating about this
amongst other things is that
it's just not supposed to be there
gobekli tepe
is thousands of years before before
stonehenge um even longer before the
high civilizations
of antiquity and yet there's this
there's this megalithic
monumental architecture uh which klaus
schmidt the original archaeologist who
is now deceased
talked about the depiction of some kind
of gods and and if
if there was spirituality um in
prehistory that this has something to do
with that
but what's strange about quebec liteview
to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas